whoo
morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning so rush but what happened was
comes with Jana snitches showed up to
work and we were also taken off guard we
had to catch up with her know what
really happened was that Jackie and I
are both baring our thighs today and we
needed an extra 10 minutes to mentally
prepare yeah and to approve all images
and angles from what I saw previously it
looks like I had a muscle that was
exciting
so um people are new pays off people on
YouTube
be kind okay yeah how are you there are
people out here being unbelievably brave
yeah I am good you know she rest as hell
yeah excited for you well if you're not
sure day's event are you really a bride
no you're really not
that's a good tweet my girl break that
down Thank You counselor thank you come
Saudi Ollie come to yell at a speech as
maestro we made a big announcement on
our Instagram yesterday yeah we are
releasing some merch on Valentine's Day
just cause like you know we love you and
we love the toast and we love making
funny we have some really cute merch
coming out different stuff
well we'll post like the items maybe one
today yeah no we we have that whole
rollout plan yeah it's really exciting
and also exciting is the sorority
sweatshirts will be back for details
they were supposed to be a one-time only
thing that you guys love them so much
and some of you didn't get a chance to
get them and their sellers to be a part
of the morning for sorority that's the
point of the story it's inclusive and
the best sellers obviously pop sockets
hats etc yeah what else happened to me
last night if you look really nothing I
watch just to cable you recap it at the
enemy to so I want to up my TV this week
it's like really I'm keeping up with all
my homework
yes Nikki's really hard for me because
MTV isn't on YouTube TV so I watch it on
the app on my TV which just means I have
to watch it live and I can't pause and
it's so much pressure like that someone
doesn't walk in and I just couldn't stay
paying attention to it last night um but
I last night's episode was also bad
which is why maybe that's why as a human
with the possibility I also didn't enjoy
it but we also get screeners I don't
know do you get that I know but I like
to watch some of my TV just letting you
know you know with the zeitgeist and
Twitter and snitches stories you know
like so we have Jackie and Jennifer
obviously from her houses in New Jersey
they'll be joining us in about 30 or so
minutes so if you haven't left a
question yet feel free to leave a
comment on our Instagram but the photo
of them so much you discuss
them new Real Housewives of New Jersey
tonight is it the finale tonight I don't
think so no okay cannot leave I know me
neither and like I say when the finale
is just like sprung on you right but I
need to get the vibes before we do that
and it's without it is our pleasure no
further ado without further ado with
great honor that we present to you the
Fast Five story is that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay first story
that it's just you know everyone's
talking about it's so sweet Jennifer
Lawrence is engaged to cook Maroney who
art dealer
Jennifer Lee Elia Maroney are engaged
sources exclusively told page six buzz
of the engagement began after the two
were spotted having a cozy dinner at
Raul's and Lawrence 28 was rocking a
massive ring on her finger
Lawrence's rep confirmed that the two
will be tying a knot but we hear that
Lawrence has been sharing the news with
those closest to her a rat wolves quote
it was a giant rock they seemed like
they were celebrating and people were
talking about it the ring was very
noticeable they were sitting back in a
corner she was wearing a cute black
dress with white polka dots a spy told
us cue okie couple were also spotted
dining at Elios on the Upper East Side
over the weekend oh and love me some
Ilyas I just have a million thoughts one
art dealer that's like the shadiest like
profession and I'm sure there are some
like legit art dealers and I'm sure cook
Maroney is probably one of them but like
what I think our dealer I just think of
Peter skarsgård in an education what is
that
what what's an education the movie I'm
waiting you ever saw an education
yeah my friend's mom Wilma when we are
in high school said you all have to see
this movie every young girl should see
it and she was right I can leave you
haven't seen an education there's a mic
responding for you it is such an
important film Jackie you have to watch
it is it as important as this the
children's place that you made us watch
much more important I mean the girl who
who is the main character is incredibly
annoying she's that girl you know I
think she was also Gatsby Daisy
does she have brown hair though in real
life I don't know she's like a Maggie
Gyllenhaal Jeffrey head of the pixie
crew I can't you know who really I'm
branched out from the pixie crew
Michelle Williams yes yeah she was one
of them but now she grew her hair and
she bought a wig
she was in oh I love her and she made
two great choices in life one was the
greatest showman and two was I feel for
Nia
totally Avery LeClair yeah um okay it's
right back to Jenna maroney's brother
marrying Jennifer Lawrence I'm so
excited for her I love her so much she's
so beautiful
I just wish you know she would step out
more often and give us some more like
inspo because everyone moves using the
same picture of her and like a little
dress and I was just like I need more
dresses like this she's so private but
she also has like a weird dating history
like she never in dates someone who's
just like universally hot you know like
that furnace guy Nicolas hold like now I
think he's hot because he had sex with
Jennifer Lawrence but like before there
are Mike who was a skinny British man
she was dating then it was that Darren
Aronofsky fella who was mad old and
wrinkly and I was like mmm not really my
type but to each their own that was a
weird time for her this guy is he cute
and even look at his face yeah he's cute
he's getting he's contemporary and get
with his camo jacket and t-shirt very
Scott Disick yeah I feel like this is a
good match for her she clearly doesn't
like to date someone who's in the
spotlight and I just want her to be
happy and I feel like she hasn't
actually really normal life yes she has
a she maintains a semblance of normalcy
she's actually the biggest actress in
the world yeah but it's cuz she lives in
New York like you I mean us celebrities
that live in New York now how easy it is
to maintain a normal life right stay
grounded value than number one morning
show right right now
yeah like playing right now the Today
Show just ended yeah she's she's very
private it's like as a consumer of her
work and a fan of hers it's a little
annoying but I respect her her privacy
right like I could go for some Instagram
shots of her like I could just go for an
Instagram right but I'll take what I can
get I would love to see the ring and
she's gonna make a beautiful breath do
you remember when that picture of her
went viral with all of her male cast
mates in Paris it was freezing and she
was wearing this dress with no sleeves
and everyone else was like bundled up in
coats and like it went viral like this
is an indication of feminism the
expectations and it was like this really
well-thought-out
paragraph on feminism and she does
responded like knows beautiful dress and
they may want to wear a coat that was
just so great like sometimes it's not
that complicated sometimes it isn't but
sometimes it is right this is a general
she was like I know like literally was
writing this expensive dress why would I
wear a coat yeah that's it
I was singing about this last night
because we have to wear gowns tonight
that's what I was gonna say speaking of
expensive dresses speaking expensive
dresses and the coats you wear with them
like when you wear a dress to the floor
inevitably your coat is gonna be shorter
because you don't want some people do
wear a coat to the floor but that is a
bold look yeah
so you wear your coat even if it's a
fancy coat like it goes to the calf yeah
and it's just a weird look you know I'm
out I actually as I was falling asleep
last night I decided that today I'm not
wearing a coat and that right and then I
was thinking like what are the fancies
people do like on Gossip Girl when they
go to the downs
they wear the [ __ ] coat to the calf
and it's weird that is weird well Jack
and I are wearing fancy gowns tonight
because we are going to the amfAR gala
which is a great cause but also a great
seat and a great place to take pictures
TPG has invited us and we are so
grateful eternally great we haven't
stopped talking about how excited we are
but also how grateful we are for him to
have given his precious seats to just
like two nobodies you know and I like
the reading with Ben oh yeah Ben's
coming to I had forgotten all about it
and then yesterday you sent a picture of
the dress you bought which apparently
you've been thinking about for weeks and
decided not to tell me I'm still not
sure I was thinking about it for a week
and a week ago I was in the chat sending
pictures I was already in Mexico of ugly
dresses at Saks
I was already in Mexico and there was
nothing to do about it so I landed
yesterday and you literally reminded me
that the thing was tomorrow okay today
so yesterday I cleared my entire
schedule I went to Bloomingdale's just
as like a formality to check stuff out
before I had it's like the the better
gown store has sacks like treachery and
I just found a gown that was in my size
that fit and was 3 hours like 300 ology
to the amfAR gala
no one's gonna be wearing a cheaper
trust in me and honestly that is a title
I graciously accept I don't know I think
you might get around for your money or
for quite like Meghan Margo wearing her
Sara or some [ __ ] like some like model
wearing thinking that being a grave yeah
yeah no but still like I was really
proud I'm like I just know everyone's
gonna love my dress I'm like so excited
about it cuz like I actually look tall I
that's the thing about a gown it makes
you look tall
oh so I went to Saks and I know we took
a hot steaming dump on them the last
time we went and like they made it right
and like they sent us really cute
packages and the gift card that I I
don't think it worked but um I wouldn't
know because Jackie took mine I went
back because they made it right so I was
like you know what I'm all about second
chance and they were having renovations
at the time like let's be fair okay by
the way they're still having animations
there Kitty's having renovations I went
back and I just I'm not gonna tear it
down because I'm just
the mood and we don't have the time yeah
I just want to make a suggestion okay
that Undercover Boss needs to go to Saks
good having you you will be in a world
of shook the people are on their phones
like the people who work there like not
trying to help anyone and when they see
you see them on their phone they're like
what client is texting me
oh shut up well maybe they're going out
of business cuz that really feels like
the vibe like acting like a bunch of
people who are going out of business I
just want to say I think Undercover Boss
I don't know who the boss of Saks Fifth
Avenue is but you should go undercover
and then you know you see for yourself
I love Undercover Boss I love it I'm
motivated to become successful and have
a thriving business with different
employees just so I can go in Undercover
Boss and pay off their debts I have
their set her dress is $60 [ __ ] where
did that [ __ ] she had to dress for $60
how do you know that it's it she said
I'm here in cédric man is coming to [ __ ]
oh and Heather McMahon's coming on the
toast tomorrow obviously to recap our
night together and her engagement and
her engagement and Jackie's just gonna
try to get a word in yes
you know what I've been tired I can do
no what if you want to take a day off
tomorrow I don't think I wanna see that
might be good I think we've got as a
mental health day no I have [ __ ] to do
okay so go to the courthouse go into the
chapel and again marry me just harmonize
yep yeah okay yeah TBD on that actually
but I need to get a courthouse look and
I'm not I'm not prepared what was the
story we just reported Jennifer Lawrence
is goin to the chapel and she's gonna
get married did it next story
ariana grande is not attending the
Grammys after after disagreements with
the producers she's not attending or
she's not performing both shout ding - a
disagreement with Grammy producers over
which songs she would perform ariana
grande who has been featured on
billboards promoting the show all over
LA not only won't be performing it at
the February 10th show she will not even
be attending it according to sources
close to the situation an insider tells
variety that granny fell quote insulted
after producers initially refused her
refused to allow her to perform seven
rings the latest single from her
forthcoming album a compromise was
reached where seven rings would be a
part of a medley
they pulled out after producers insisted
that the second song be of their
choosing [ __ ] you guys what do you know
I don't know I think about it like okay
if this was like the Billboard or
American or one of the thousand other
fake shows as an opportunity just to
promote your new single great but like
she had a remarkable year she's
nominated for a sweetener like it's only
appropriate that she performs something
from sweetener no whenever people
perform they perform their newest song
know at every other award show but not
the Grammys yes the Grammys but then the
Grammys is also like fusions could have
been seven rings with I don't know Julie
Andrews singing my favorite things I
mean it's just so incredibly odd to me
that ariana grande won't be going to
something because for her this has been
a year of getting out of bed and going
places when I just wish she would relax
and take a nap because she's so busy so
I actually like as much as I will miss
her I'm actually happy she's gonna like
take the night off I agree and you know
what if she's not performing seven rings
then everyone will [ __ ] themselves and
they're wrong they're dead wrong that is
the greatest song ever the more I listen
to it I'm making a call it's better than
Thank You max even yeah it's epic and it
would have been so good any and the
Grammys just didn't take a chance on an
unknown scene and I don't appreciate
that well now now that these reports are
coming out it's also being reported that
Taylor Swift declined the invitation to
come no bed my feelings bled blood I
like Choa preference she's just not
gonna go because it is the BAFTA Awards
and she's gonna support her boyfriend to
the actor Joe Owen as he's nominated for
the favorite which is the movie I've
heard a lot about but haven't seen and
have no interest in it's not a favorite
not at all
and I feel like yes she's definitely
like wanting to go support her boyfriend
but she's probably salty but she did get
nominated for album of the year yeah she
doesn't need to show up whatever it
doesn't even matter cuz it's the night
of Kacey Musgraves I know she's gonna
win I just have a feeling in my bones
even though Kay's Lady Gaga even though
that leaked that I didn't think was real
but a lot of people do said that someone
else want album of the year not um right
they said that hazing one album of the
year but they did say Chloe exhaling won
Best New Artist and after seeing them
perform America's the beautiful at the
Superbowl you have to watch it it was
incredible I actually heard so much
about it and you never hear about
America the Beautiful you know and I
have to say something
Chloe exhale II I hadn't heard of and
you know who I blame
jay-z because I think he's like in
charge of them Beyonce
their proteins right and like they force
they definitely forced to Chloe exhale a
to go on title and like it's no wonder I
didn't hear their music you know but
they're oh wait like title is just like
like not a thing and everyone is stop
pretending like it is and maybe if they
had partnered with Spotify like I would
have heard it
perhaps but now I'm like behind on Chloe
act ally thanks jay-z I need to catch up
I was so impressed by the by the music
and by their looks and they're so
beautiful and stylish and cute and I
think their sisters an item a special
place in my heart for sister of course
where are your sisters who support
others whoever butch a cake for them
great opportunity for them to anywhere
at Lana neat is that they really
respected the hell out of Atlanta and
they were catapulted into the mainstream
when they've been sidelined by title all
these years right and then Gladys and I
performed the star-spangled banner and
she crushed it and it was just it was so
great it was so great it's it's never so
great yeah except it was good except for
Lady gaga except for pink but who sang
America the Beautiful ask you know it's
always like a throwaway like [ __ ]
thing where they write show the people
in Iraq and like where that's what we
want to say but they don't let us and
they showed you know the the sea to
shining sea they showed you know the
four presidents on the mountain Mount
Rushmore Mount Rushmore they showed you
know all the different landscapes they
showed the Hollywood sign which is like
why did they do that they were just
showing different like landmarks
American landmarks but I just feel the
Hollywood sign was just like creepy but
the Hollywood sign is not a landmark
like it's just like they were enjoying
landmarks specifically you know I'm not
take it's not like registered as a
landmark it's just like who cares they
were just showing like iconic American
scenery okay I would say you'd say
iconic it's just a little creepy these
days yeah it really is it really taken
down it's like a symbol of like the
patriarchy being taken down because you
know those letters were dug in with just
blood sweat and abuse of power yes
exactly
okay next story is a little personal
knocking line Rachel Lindsay gets real
with bachelorettes Nick vile talking
about their season while sitting down
together for the former bachelors the
bio files podcast he and the
Bachelorette alum reflected on the time
they spent together on his season as
bachelor nation stand-ins well no Rachel
ended up being eliminated in week 9
leaving him to choose between Raven and
Vanessa who he ultimately proposed to in
August the of 2017 the ex jointly
confirmed
tewi news that they had ended their
engagement meanwhile Lindsay went on to
start about right okay Lee alright
that's not the important part
um Lindsay were called a few moments in
particular that she had never spoken
about including during the fourth week
when vile and the women traveled to this
Wisconsin quote I had been drinking I
was so upset that day she were called
him a sneak peek of the inner tube you
shared with me news I've never told this
story as she described they had a
horrible day on a farm and then saw a
violin chromoly quote have a secret
moment viola defended his ex-fiancee
claiming producers told her to find him
either way the other contestants saw it
and Lindsay got frustrated because she
thought it was obvious who he wanted to
be with so I was like why are we even
here Tony said also noting that she had
tried to quit the season three times
ultimately after being notified by a
producer vile found Lindsay sobbing in
the bathroom and she told him she didn't
want to be there in her words it was the
most embarrassing moment the former
contestant also remembered seeing a book
Grimaldi was going to show him that she
used to work with her students at the
moment during the second week Lindsay
said this [ __ ] is gonna win but
unfortunately unfortunately they knew
who he was going to pick quote I never
felt like he led me on she assured him
in fact it was so clear to Lindsay where
she stood in the show that she hugged
the crew goodbye before the rose
ceremony she was eliminated in it's been
real fun this is it for me tonight
remember telling the Cameron Sound
people I remember I was like it's not me
okay then the part that he news failed
to mention is that the morning toast
came up in this podcast episode and
honestly all I felt was shame she would
make my hell said oh I know that podcast
they really don't like me and you know
what it was definitely an opportunity
for him on his own podcast like say
something eyelashes and he did it and
like I immediately like felt really bad
and it's just really proof like you
don't know anyone
and honestly I'm Margo Hemi the basket
don't walk in front of the camera basket
with the next face in it which happens
to be the basket of people we take
umbrage and he was the inspiration
behind the basket but people can change
and I feel like the opinion I have of
Nick vile I'm just I can't with my
thighs sorry and the opinion that I have
of nick vile is that of him maybe four
years ago but he's sitting on the couch
asking Andi Dorfman why she had sex in
them and like I still think that was a
[ __ ] up thing to do but maybe I don't
know Nick vile when he literally didn't
say one negative thing about us on his
podcast when his co-host and Rachel were
both like I love the morning shows and
he was like yeah they hate me he could
have said something when we we never
miss an opportunity to say something
nice about him and you know what he is a
better person than we are
and
this is a really self reflective moment
for me when I heard it I had like a pit
in my stomach and I felt shame because I
had a pit first I'm like what is he
gonna say about us there's so many
negative things he could say you know
and they wouldn't you know not be
incorrect so he didn't and I'm just wow
like I'm I've been feeling really
ashamed of myself okay I'm officially
taking Nick vile out of the basket I
support this movement consider it
consider the feud ended on our part we
apologize we really do like really when
I heard that that we came up on the on
the podcast and he was like oh those
girls don't like me then I was like we
why didn't we like him I don't even
remember the original I just didn't want
him chosen as bachelor which is a word
the title to our opinion electorate yeah
we took it a little far and now we're
reeling it back in yeah I apologize yeah
we can admit when we're wrong and we can
admit when we've misjudged
I've been misjudged and I have misjudged
and I misjudged Nick file maybe I think
so too
someone wrote I feel like I'm witnessing
history you know like I just I just
couldn't believe he didn't say anything
nasty about us right I mean just for ya
know someone put the audio in the toast
I heard it this morning okay and then
they just moved on yeah they we come up
they were talking about Rachel said like
I don't feel like you led me astray and
then the co-host was like actually I
watched Raven gates on the morning toast
and she said that she really thought she
was gonna win because you were giving
her signs and that like she was really
surprised when she didn't win
who is this co-host intensive research
she was like literally mentioning things
Raven said I don't even remember
Raven being here let alone what she said
because I have dementia who is the
co-host I don't know she was like I love
the morning shows she said that it was
like I do too so looks like I have a new
best friend and I'm so impressed they
make file for choosing a co-host who's
so well-versed and has such great taste
and has such great taste so it was just
like a real moment for me I feel like it
alas no weight has been less if you like
in the last two hours I grew up you know
I feel like a mature woman no it's like
in my sweater nothing happens for
decades and then decades have at any
moment decades happening J and a decade
happened today
Wow who else can we relieve hate from
that's it
that's what China is gonna come out and
say some nice things about us she's
still on my list Wow you feel okay I do
I feel good I know I feel good too
to get rid of a grudge it's also nice to
be nice sweet well it really is let's
say kind things okay I'm sorry are
incredible counts are a decent intern
but a great counselor you're getting
better
Clara you look beautiful today I know I
don't look beautiful no you need to run
down no no you look just so inspiring
today thank you I'm trying to wear less
makeup so that my skin can breathe a
little bit yeah and I've been like after
the show I've been going home and
looking in the mirror and it's like
crust ah I know the feeling so I didn't
even wear highlighter today because it
was contributing to a crust that's the
thing about highlighters I thing is they
are dressing
okay next story very know fourth story
but it's now we're into the news section
FAA investigators assessing mechanics
complaints may be interpreting
regulations differently okay they need
to speak English basically
Mechanics for American Airlines and
Southwest Airlines have been feeling
pressure to not report mechanical issues
to get flights out on time oh [ __ ]
mechanics unions are strongly
criticizing American and Southwest
Airlines after an 8-month CBS News
investigation raised questions not the
oversight of aircraft maintenance in
interviews with 26 airline mechanics at
Southwest American Airlines all
expressed concerns about undue pressure
to cut corners and not write up issues
to get planes back and service faster
the claims are consistent with FAA with
so globe our complaints and at least 32
anonymous industry-wide reports since
2015 well in the past eight months I've
actually never flown Southwest
we flew American Airlines to Miami and
you know what I didn't feel safe and I
don't why you're comfortable and I
didn't feel happy and I got my bag
checked when it was like totally able to
fit above the overhead bin space which
is really [ __ ] annoying and I I said I
phoned Southwest once and I think my my
preconceived notions about it were so
bad that you like get tricks on your
plane yeah well because someone said
it's general admission like a concert
but you can pay to be in like a zone you
everyone gets a spot in line so you're
number one two three four up to like 200
however many seats are on the plane and
the number one chooses our seat first
number two number three so we were like
number 10 so my god that just seems so
config like pay for that spot in line so
it's not like you ever getting true
no but it was actually fine and they
served Wheaton's and I hadn't had a
wheat thin and so long and I enjoyed
myself I can keep Wheat Thins in my
pantry but then since then two people
have almost been sucked out of the plane
so for that reason I'm out on Southwest
yeah
nd it happened and I was bullied by an
American airline age in a couple months
ago and I'm done with them yes like
hardcore bolita I tears my eyes today
but like I wasn't I wasn't like I wasn't
holding back she had tears in her eyes -
uh I wonder if CVG is gonna be you know
like all torn up about this tonight well
I will ask him I just think that like
when when corporate greed you know goes
as far as to put us in jeopardy in terms
of our safety I just think that's really
greedy borderline unethical but really
just sad you know how quick we are to
make a buck
that we but you know what then I'm also
that person on the plane complaining
like we're delayed and I'm just like oh
my catechol issue right there like
there's something broken so but so it
depends like on my flight to where was I
just oh in Mexico the coffee machine
wasn't working and they had like this
guy on or like one time there was one
seat where the seat belt was stuck in
between it and literally couldn't come
out they had to get like three
technicians on to like remove the seat
and it's just like you know what make
that person get off the plane okay and
give them a first-class seat on the next
flight like so you know what that's
where I think cutting corners
I need more specifics is it like oh this
engine might die but probably not we
have a two engine right just guess silly
you know I'd have thought on the plane
yes actually I had a hilarious thought
and I was trying to formulate it into a
joke but I didn't and now I'm gonna try
now here you are
the thing about perspective is that it's
really funny okay it's all about
perspective you guys some people
consider it Sully in American Hero but
some people consider him a bird murderer
a murderer like what about those birds
where's PETA you know just saying yes he
seems a lot of people but he killed a
whole [ __ ] ton of birds just my thoughts
but the birds are the villains the birds
came for the people you know I fell he
saved the people no he didn't come forth
they went sucked in against their way oh
no here's the thing
Sully is in a big plane in the sky you
know if you can
see above him or below him really and
the birds are these tiny things that see
a big plane and they go right into it
I'm just going to talk to TPG about
maybe writing an op-ed piece for the
points guy calm because I do feel like
this is you know uncharted territory
yeah in the head then will be this silly
American hero or devious predator
question mark I mean he's definitely
devious because I still haven't gotten
my fixtures Jacky was snubbed at AFI
silly but it's really crazy because up
until that moment in my life like I
thought about Sully once once a day then
it turn into one speak like I just
constantly think about Sully now after
that like out of be done out of sight
out of mind
done with him okay last story before we
bring out our housewives okay
interesting story from National
Geographic affect future generations
have we ever written from National
Geographic read from national endeavor I
don't know but in the next sector II
satellites will watch as the oceans
blues and greens intensified by 2100 is
that what we're gonna call it the ocean
as we know it is likely to change color
that was the conclusion of a study
published Monday and the journal not
Nature communications okay this sounds a
little Shh try anything of the
instagrams the purple ocean no and it's
like now that it's green you can turn it
like with preset right can make it like
futuristic we don't have to wait till
2100 between two the color of the ocean
on our instagrams left to right okay
nature communications i'm unfamiliar
with that but if another study bees
cancer one is from geographic it's
closed according them i'm gonna grade
that modeled how Philo plankton will
change as oceans continue to warm under
a business-as-usual scenario in which
greenhouse gas emissions continue
unabated the bluest subtropical zones of
the ocean will become bluer and greener
regions long equator and poles will
become greener more than just an oddity
the changing color is a warning signs
say the study authors of drastic global
changes that will take place in a world
warmed by climate change
okay Leonardo DiCaprio it's like
literally your job to fix this that's
what your whole instagram account is
devoted to so if we're not gonna get
cute pictures of you like fix it so it's
gonna be more blue and more green okay
when I
first of the story I thought it was
changed you know like orange oh [ __ ] I
mean more saturated yeah um so and
apparently it's a bad thing but like it
sounds like a good thing like the colors
are good no I love color you know I mean
it sounds like it's a result of a bad
thing I'm just saying like they're
saying like this is it's gonna happen
and it's bad but I'm like really just
sounds more and more beautiful I'm
looking forward to it now I'm getting
climate change is not a joke yeah don't
try I don't know to go from blue to
bluer isn't really news right thanks
National Geographic like there are words
that are dying in the sky take care of
that first see you know we call that a
callback before we looking at the real
houses in New Jersey have some shameless
self-promoter
I have now Jude a very popular to man
people are just hounding me edit another
show in Irvine and another show in
Houston so it's a third show in Houston
in a second in Irvine presale for my
patreon lovers goes on sale tomorrow
tomorrow noon so right after we wrap the
show I am thinking that I'm going to add
another Foxwoods show because a lot of
people been asking I didn't think I was
even gonna sell it the first one I
really thought I was gonna have to
cancel it so now the fact that I have to
add a second one like I just love the
toaster so much and I just want to buy
the mall presents for making me look
cool to other people you know I'm so
stay tuned for that and I believe we are
adding an is her another Dallas show
because the first one sold out so
quickly like literally it's I'm at the
new agency and they were like so it was
a first show we put on sale together and
they were like oh she's legit now
everyone respects me thanks toasters
okay are you ready if you have a
question for Jennifer or Jackie please
feel free to leave it on our Instagram
account or leave it on a comment as a
YouTube stream we are going to take a
quick break and we will be back with two
premium asks New Jersey housewives we'll
see you then
Thanks
okay we are back and we're very excited
to have both of our two new favorite
real houses in New Jersey Jackie and
Jennifer hello guys very confusing
getting two new housewives Jackie and
Jennifer like the Jays it was computing
the beginning but now you both establish
yourselves that you're your own
personalities and we really appreciate
the work that you're doing to bring back
this season every bring in the James you
are it is great have you guys um how do
you watch the show previously did you
only think about it like do you guys
live in the same town as any other
leading County action okay so I'm right
next I'm in the town next door to
Margaret okay but and you don't leave
anybody no I don't think that I'm in
Paramus but I mean I'm originally from
Long Island I moved to Jersey seven
years ago and you know now I love it
well this season has just been so good
so many moments that just really shook
me to my core
last week especially monkeys [ __ ]
like just the greatest thing really that
ever happened to tell them it was so
funny and like we can't something
probably like I people see me on the
street and they're like from housewives
a monkey's ass never look so good
sweetheart
: and yes so funny what has it been like
to like a round town but also just like
doing press like having people come up
and now recognize you from the show was
a show so popular I mean I've been
having a lot of love from the monkeys
[ __ ] people are coming up to me
telling me they think a monkey's [ __ ]
is cute which I agree a hundred percent
you know everyone's been inquiring about
my like lip routine lip liner the
perfect monkey's [ __ ] I use actually
the Kylie Jenner lip kids yeah in the
mattes in cocoa or candy however I don't
use the lip liner that comes with it I'd
like to use a deeper like Winer wine
colored because I like the contrast it's
like my signature thing I know it's the
90s I don't give up you know is my thing
and I like to make the lip a little bit
more nude and then when I blend it with
the lip liner it's all nice and
pink and outlined for your pleasure and
I don't have a monkey's ass no she is
mine's a little thinner it's more like a
squirrel oh my god I still get a lot of
love yeah my lips but you know in
general for other things yeah you have
beautiful lips I think I think Jackie
your lips are super cute thank you
they're not monkeys as well but they're
very cute well I have a question because
in this present moment and I know this
was filmed a while ago I mean you two
were kind of divided in the sense that
you're really close with Margaret and
Melissa and you have become really close
with Teresa and there's there's a divide
in the group how do you guys as us do
you have a friendship in and of yourself
and there was some crack to the article
and all that but how do you manage to
stay friends without like taking sides
you know I think that um what would I
have with Teresa has nothing to do with
Jennifer and my relationship so I think
we're pretty good at separating the two
we don't see each other that often I
mean I really like Jennifer and she
really likes me I think I'm like a
regular basis I would say I'm definitely
very very close with Margaret and
Melissa and yeah pretty close with
Teresa yeah but um that doesn't spill
over into what we're we're okay with
yeah we're both like reasonable adults
you know when we're not when I'm not
drinking tequila right so I think we
were able to just you know yeah we'll
see friends what we love so much when
you're saying about your fate with
Margaret was like it was an iconic sight
and we got great one-liners but then you
guys immediately apologized and moved on
so it wasn't like a pit in your stomach
where do you guys stand right now with
you and Margaret you know what I have to
say I'm an Aries and so is Margaret and
one thing about our sign is that we
don't hold a grudge we get over things I
mean I know with me being in areas I get
over things within five minutes it's
like one of the things that have been
like a secret underlying grace period
thing that I'm that I get along with my
husband so well because I get over
things and I never hold a grudge so
she's the same way so like we could say
something get really mad about it the
heat of the moment and then five minutes
later I'm literally over it I mean I was
watching and I'm like I'm giggling but
yeah that's me I get
I also have a nervous laugh so was there
like a moment think you guys were
dreading watching or that hasn't
happened yet or any time this season
that like you knew you did or said
something like you just didn't want to
relive I think tonight's episode I'm
gonna dread watching only because I just
I'm I'm I'm tequila toxic and it's it's
not good and I'm not a fun drunk I'm
actually not a big drinker
what people don't my people like my
brother and they're like your sister's
an alcoholic and he's like you don't
understand she does not drink I don't
drink that much because I can't handle
my alcohol right oh my husband will kick
me under the table and then I need a bed
right I peek at 20 minutes which is very
not nice but a lot can happen in two
other Lots can happen in 20 minutes and
then I need to go to sleep and I need
sweatpants so it's not fun so I really
like my water with ice got it but when
I'm with these ladies and also we were
in Mexico you know like we're gonna have
either Corona which I don't drink beer
or some tequila no the other thing money
I drink and she's hotter I get the party
started yeah and I have a person I'm
dancing on the table they are fun drunks
I don't like get to that point it's a
bad thing yeah really it really could go
either way so if are you if assuming you
to come back next season would you drink
again on the show next season I think
I'm gonna change my choice of alcohol
for now okay I'm gonna say I mean we
went to a wine tasting so I'm also no I
don't want to go to a wine tasting and
not drink wine right you know I don't
want to go to Mexico and not have an
alcoholic beverage but however like I'll
go to an event like Margaret's event
that you'll see tonight and I don't
drink it I don't need a cocktail right
it might be legal to smoke weed in
Jersey by that point so we're just going
to try that I would love to watch that
would be fun did your brother get
married yet no his we're waiting for a
visa for his fiancee the drama we had
she got denied a turistic visa so we
just hired an attorney and we're doing
everything by the book and we're getting
a fiance visa and that could take some
like three to six months which we're in
the homestretch of that so hopefully
within the next month or two she'll be
here I hope how many bedrooms are in
your house which one do you use like use
everyone for family I use so the master
has
- and there's nine bedrooms so there's
10 right off the bat just for the
bedroom so if you think about it the
rest of the house has six it's really
not that much sounds lovely
yeah there seems to be a common thread
this season with the fights it's like
it's just a regular girl drama until
someone's like family or kids or husband
gets brought up and then it's like
crossing the line do you think like
anyone will like that will change it's
just like it seems as a viewer it's so
obvious it's like everyone can really
get along until you start talking about
people as kids husbands so like why
don't we just sup I think that people
know it's such a trigger that if you're
fighting with somebody and you're
getting really heated and it's you're
not getting to the place you want to go
like that's the button you push hurt
them right that's the button you push to
hurt them and it's it's hard to resist
you know I personally wouldn't do it
like it I just don't like it hurting
people's children and I know how angry I
would be if someone said anything about
my husband I'm really protective of him
but it is very tempting to push that
button because Brio that went off so
then do you get why Jennifer was so
upset about that article I get it but I
don't think that the article was
insulting no I wasn't I was sorry about
hurting her coming from a parent's
perspective
anyone who has small children you know
when you bring them to school they make
you sign a release if you want any of
their pictures being allowed to be
posted on Facebook my point is people
don't even like pictures of their kids
being posted on social media yeah
regardless even if you said that my kids
were the biggest joy how can a parent
not be offended by saying it's almost
like wait a second take that picture
down and take that article down yeah if
she - you know [ __ ] before bulge us out
really would know like if she had asked
me right here obviously yeah I mean if
she asked me that she was writing the
article I mean I don't think I would
have been happy about it but maybe I
would have respect I mean and who knows
yeah only God knows but I would have
made respected or for coming to me first
totally how have your families enjoyed
being on the show one filming and - like
the reception and just afterwards my
kids loved it they loved watching it
back they really do I go out with
friends to watch some of the episodes
the ones weren't I'm home with them like
they just can't get enough they love
seeing themselves on screen and my
husband started off that's so cute like
I don't want to be a big part of it like
it's about you it's not about me and he
was resistant at first and now he has
drank the kool-aid
I know we've used that a lot but it
fully househusbands my hope - well the
husband's a seasoned really like have
their own crew and it's so great and did
you think your husband's next season
will join the Marty and Marty's at Joe
Gorga party so my husband and Joe Gorga
and joe Benigno they get along really
really well and they've gotten out
before and everything I don't think my
husband my husband's more of like a
homebody than they are they like to
party a little more than he does so I
don't think it'll be quite as much as
they go out together but I already know
that they've made some plans and they
really enjoy being together so
definitely a little bit yeah what about
you my husband gets along with everybody
I mean he's more of like you know in the
work zone and a professional and unable
to come to a lot of these things but I
think if he's able to come I mean you're
gonna see him tonight at Margaret's
party and he was a joy to be around I
mean he has been getting he's been
getting like some slack right you know
on social media some people are saying
he's strict and of course the comments
are never end well that was my next
question so the Bravo fan base is quite
passionate and sometimes that can be
negative especially on Twitter or social
media how do you deal with people who
have no idea who you are like judging
your parenting your career or anything
like that for me I feel like if it's a
nasty vulgar comment I almost get a
little bit of joy because I'm gonna
block and delete them right and I think
to my head and they sit there and they
think like oh my god under her skin she
blocked me it's like wait a second who
are you I don't even remember who you
are but yet you will forever remember me
by the next time that I have something
fantastic that makes social media and
makes the news you're gonna want to come
to my page and see it and guess what you
have been blocked so whose skin did I
get under mine or yours I would think
that's why I leo Bethenny go it's a
little bit of a joy thing for me when I
see like it's like the vulgar is nasty
comment I'm like yes yes I want block
block oh oh baby not me no in terms of
family I've been so blessed my children
and my husband people really seem to
like them I mean my kids have been
getting really positive feedback people
evidence not on that much but like I
really have gotten like no negative
feedback for me personally I got a lot
about my appearance which before I
started this I thought I was kind of
pretty but I mean I was like it was like
all of a sudden like everyone was like
you have a crooked face and I'm like oh
good face so I would look in the
beginning of season I would look at the
mirror and I'm like and then I was like
[ __ ] it like a face I don't have a Chris
but you know um I also haven't had a
gallon of the lip implants I'm not
talking about you I'm just talking in
general about your exact role I mean I
get it once like a year but I have a
good right
so I have pretty natural lips and like
they're not the fullest thing in the
world but I would get comments about the
way lips move and this and that and then
I think somewhere after the first few
weeks of beating myself up I realized
that like it will never stop no matter
what you do to yourself so I think that
I'm pretty and I hope I hope all girls
out there think that they're beautiful
enough as is so I'm just you know I
learned to like yeah they comment on my
nose we get my husband's a plastic
surgeon how come you fix my nose and my
god like this is what I wedding pictures
I haven't had any plastic surgery on my
face and I have like liposuction once
you get liposuction you're fat I don't
know what I'm in my happy place I'm
never gonna be a swimsuit model I have
16 bathrooms right okay before we let
you go one last question you guys just
film the reunion yes is your first
ringing in each how did it go what were
you feeling going into it and like are
you okay did you feel coming out I was
nervous going into it I just didn't want
anyone to like I don't know without some
private investigator follow that they
found something that I had no idea about
or a text messages that maybe where I
don't know I was nervous about it it got
crazy for a minute I mean
I wasn't nervous at all and I went in
actually being like I'm cool with
everyone like nothing's gonna happen
today and that is their read on how it
went down so stay tuned
Wow how many parts you think it's gonna
be do you guys know Oh publicist is like
shut up
oh yeah well the husband's new jersey
new episode tonight very exciting and
clapping Brava
hopefully three-part reunion nine
o'clock on Bravo we will be there are
you guys can you love tweeting are we
gonna yeah I always like to eat I'll be
on a flight to Miami so I won't be able
to the last few times I haven't been
able to live tweet cuz I'm doing
something and everyone's like oh you're
so quiet I'm like I don't know how to
use Twitter screeching follow you
instagrams keep up with you guys on
Instagram
Jackie gold Schneider on Instagram and
JG snipe on Twitter just Jennifer Aiden
Jennifer Aiden Jennifer Aiden very boy
so every switch 10480 trying to pray a
tan a ydi a Turkish last night thank you
guys for tuning in we will see you
tomorrow with Heather McMahon bye bye
you